[Music]
you are watching the press preview a
first look at what's on the front pages
as they arrive it's time to see what's
making the headlines with the political
editor of wales online ruth masalski and
the mail's deputy political editor john
stevens they'll be with us from now
until just before midnight
so let's see what's on some of those
front pages for you now
the metro declares the gigs up boris as
mr johnson now faces a parliamentary
inquiry into partygate and growing calls
from his own mps to resign
picturing the pm on his trip to india
the telegraph describes him as buckling
to pressure for an investigation
the times has a similar headline
the mail asks how long can the partygate
fast go on
the guardian calls today a day of
humiliation for boris johnson
the daily mirror seems relieved that
some tory mps are turning against him
according to the financial times there
could be another row over brexit as the
government may introduce legislation
that effectively rips up the northern
ireland trade protocols
the daily express reports that british
scientists are on the verge of a
revolutionary new cancer treatment
thanks to breakthroughs in finding
genetic clues to the disease
and the star looks at the rivalry
between tv host piers morgan and nigel
farage and their relationship with
donald trump
and reminded that by scanning the qr
code you'll see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's newspapers while you
watch us
and joining me tonight ruth masalski and
john stevens welcome to you both let's
um start off by taking a look at the
telegraph front page the headline there
we're concentrating on johnson buckles
over party inquiry and this is the
inquiry that's uh
gone through while we'll
be going ahead after the vote into the
uh never-ending party gate scandal john
yeah it's been a really miserable day
for boris johnson i think there's been a
real mood change in westminster even
from just yesterday the tory seemed
confident that they'd be able to vote
down this labor motion they'd be able to
get boris johnson to avoid this third
investigation into partygate but
something's gone really wrong for them
and
you know the toy party's got a 75 strong
working majority they should easily be
able to vote down a labor motion
criticizing boris johnson but they
failed to do that and i think that shows
that under the surface
even though tory mps haven't been that
vocally critical of the prime minister
since he was fined last week that a lot
of them behind the scenes aren't happy
and clearly the whips got spooked and
thought they weren't able to get this
motion voted down
uh ruth it shows that his owner are
turning on him doesn't it
yeah it was a really interesting day
wasn't it it was quite bewildering day
as well at times you know it looked like
we were definitely gonna have to
remember we're gonna have a motion and
an amendment to sort of we were finally
gonna see some um
votes and see how some mps felt about it
um and that just didn't happen and so it
felt like a bit of a damn script in the
end and yes boris johnson will appear in
front of this committee but it's the
third investigation we're not going to
have um in relation to partygate there's
no timeline on any of them um
so it's
yes it was interesting to see that some
of the conservatives have turned against
him some publicly like steve baker
and but it was also interesting to see
that you know a lot is always made i
think of pictures of the common benches
that are empty especially during key
debates and you often see the sort of
floating around twitter you know why
doesn't my mp care about this hugely
important issue but i think it was quite
telling like which mps weren't there in
the commons and how empty some of those
those constant adventures did look at
times you know this is a really key day
for boris johnson and like john says on
tuesday it felt like there was huge
support boris johnson was very
boisterous there was and it felt like a
change in tone but today it has
completely changed and why that's
happened you know there's lots of
theories floating around but no real
answer yet
the guardian uh characterizing it as a
day of humiliation for the prime
minister john would you agree with that
yeah i think definitely and you spoke
with people around westminster today
and
for the first time in quite a while they
do just feel there was this
stench of death almost around the
government and boris johnson people
starting to talk again about when he
will leave downing street
and i think up until now people had
thought that yeah things had been quite
rocky but he'd be able to get through
this
and that he might get back on the up
again
but today i just think it was such a bad
day and it clearly shows that his
support in the toy party there are a lot
of wavering people and i think that if i
was in number 10 i'd be really worried
tonight
i've previously described the prime
minister as a teflon coated uh ruth do
you think that exterior is being chipped
a way out will he survive
i mean the male's asking how long can
this go on westminster when this isn't
debated where people aren't sharing
their stories of what they missed out on
cobra we could all share our stories
about the momentous life moments we
missed and no one is going to forget
where they were on these days that there
were parties happening down the street
and one of the mps of today and says how
much one of her constituents would have
loved that nine minutes you know saying
it was just nine minutes was it's just
unacceptable and it is none of us are
going to forget this pandemic quickly
and it means that numbers are going to
forget these breaches quickly either and
as this goes on and on and on which it
could do for a very very long time we're
all gonna be reminded of that almost
every day and i think part of the
problem is that conservative activists
are out on the doorsteps at the minute
because there's local elections and they
are going to be being told this
day after day in house after house and
that is going to have an effect on them
and it's definitely it seems to be
having an effect on mps isn't it
but yes quite but john this this does
have to to come to an end are the male
asking that question how long can
partygate go on for um but it does have
to come to a conclusion at some point
doesn't it
yeah and i think the problem though for
boris johnson is this this could get
even worse we know there's other parties
that police are still investigating the
police have said today that they're not
going to announce any more fines until
after the local elections in a
fortnight's time but we had a warning
today from sir bob neal who's a senior
toy mp he said that he was still
supporting boris johnson for the time
being but he suggested if there were
more fines that he might change his mind
and the other way that this could get
even worse the prime minister is that so
far we haven't seen any pictures of the
12 gatherings that the police have been
investigating we've seen some pictures
of other ones like a christmas quiz that
the police haven't been looking at but
we haven't seen any actual images of
boris johnson at any of these parties
that the police have been investigating
and one of the things that this
committee of privileges that is now
going to be investigating the prime
minister has the power to do is to
compel downing street to hand over these
hundreds of pictures that were gathered
by sue gray as part of her investigation
the senior civil service official and
there's the possibility that they could
put those into the public domain and we
know how powerful pictures can be
i think that this could be really
damaging for the prime minister if he
starts to think that he can move on from
this and suddenly we see a picture of
him with a drink in his hand living it
up on these parties and i think you'll
see the wound ripped open right again
and then i think you will start to see
tory mps asking the question how long
can this go on and maybe the only way to
stop it is by getting with boris johnson
from downing street yes as you say
possibly that there's so much more to
come um ruth i wonder if you can comment
on
the comments of of steve baker i mean
they've got to sting particularly um for
boris johnson because he's a staunch
brexiteer and credits himself with
getting boris johnson into to number 10
as others do and he's very well
respected and that's got to hurt hasn't
it
yeah he was positioned front and center
in the comments when he made when he
made these comments and he will have
absolutely known the coverage they'd
have got and the metro's carried it in
big bold letters on the front the gig is
up boris um having an ally turn against
him you know when i think beth rugby put
that question to him when she spoke to
in india today the prime minister and he
sort of said you know i've apologized i
understand the anger the lines we've
heard him say for weeks and months now
but there's no way that these sort of
these very sort of people that are close
to women these people that are
influential in the party turning against
him and doing so publicly and let's not
forget like we always say with these
that the 19 we don't know how many
letters have gone to the 1922 committee
we don't know what a lot of mps um are
saying i know a lot of the welsh
conservative mps have stayed very quiet
and a couple of the notables of cabinet
members all right members have been a
bit more vocal but we don't know what a
lot of them are thinking so when one of
them does stand up especially someone
like steve baker it says something as
blunt as this it is of course going to
make an impact
welcome back you're watching the press
preview still with me ruth masalski and
john stevens welcome back to both of you
let's take a look at the guardian
and this quite chilling story um
evidence from the mayor of mariopol as
to
mass graves that have been dug by
russian troops he's estimating that more
than 20 000 residents
have been killed since russian forces
began attacking the city ruth
yeah it's another horrific human
interest story from um ukraine
the the story is that the
ukrainian the mayor of the city has said
that russian trucks have been collecting
corpses and using dump trucks to put
them in mass graves
um and then there was a u.s company that
released images of what appears to be
that mass grave and also there's lots of
verification going on that is what these
pictures show
but
it's the sort of numbers that you hear
in these sort of stories that are just
so hard
to compute you've got the mayor saying
that twenty thousand mario paul
residents have been um killed since the
start of this invasion and that and it
was only about eighty years ago in world
war two that twelve thousand married
paul residents were killed not far from
here i think in some ways it's easy to
forget that it's not that long ago that
these communities were dealing with you
know mass murder on this sort of scale
recovering from that there was no way
that anyone thought that would be
happening you know a handful of decades
on and seeing these sort of images you
know that the soft images we all grew up
seeing from the nazi era it just it's
just insane to think that we're back
there now
and massively heartbreaking you know you
can't imagine
the people there the families the
families here around the world trying to
sort of look at that i'm wondering is my
family member in in that grave yes and
the mayor saying that it's hard to be
precise with the the civilian figures of
uh
those killed uh it's just an estimate so
it could be many many more than the 20
000 that he has estimated um and in the
article that they're detailing these
mobile crematoriums that the russians
are using just grim detail
yeah to scrim detail and then just try
to find any way they can to get rid of
these huge numbers of bodies of people
that they've killed because they want to
try and get rid of the evidence of the
war crimes
they've committed and obviously this is
still going on this isn't something that
has stopped and the russian military are
obviously very keen to take this city
it's very important strategically for
them
at the moment there was still a big
ukrainian resistance inside a steel
works in the city one of the newspapers
talks about how underneath the steel
works there's this massive network of
tunnels it's almost like a city
underneath the steel works and the
russians are now surrounding that and
cutting them off from anything going in
and out of there so by no means this is
over it looks like it's going to
continue indeed uh john and rufa thank
you both for taking us through the
papers see in the next town